for his new summer collection Bobby Cola
day drew inspiration from sources as
diverse as West African tribes and 1990s
hip hop icons
226 looks at the collection show an
innovative patchwork of materials and
styles it's only his 4th show ever but
the young fashion designer is a media
sensation he's even been dubbed of
wonder kid it's quite new and fresh and
different a lot of color which often I
don't see on the bed in fashion week at
work so for me that's really exciting
yes yeah we were hoping his father he
doesn't work with black at all not even
the soles of the shoes are black because
he simply doesn't want to work with this
color he's known for being very colorful
but to stick to that in every small
detail that's very interesting rather
than to the Sun it really goes places
and whether we're a lot of people are
gonna go want to go along with it is
it's open but he's really a designer in
the true sense of the word right up to
the start of the Berlin Fashion Week
Bobby kala day was still regularly
heading over to his studio in Berlin's
multicultural working-class district of
bidding but he won't let cameras in vina
distance i naught will feel ed for me
it's a place where so many ideas are
still taking shape I just don't want to
show that mr. Danish diagnosis Isis
would you let someone film on your
bedroom mom yes or no I don't think so 9
love nice our studio is just a very
personal spa yes victory I ins as their
position short holiday was born in Sudan
to a Nigerian mother and a German father
and then grew up in Uganda he studied
fashion design in Berlin and worked at
Parisian fashion houses for two years
the collection he did as his final
project one him a Berlin fashion award
in 2013 he started his own label his
design show the influences of his
African origins as well as vivid colors
and great cuts
his Blazers for example are assembled
from 39 individual pieces holiday also
has a taste for unusual materials this
jacket is made of tree bark busslin
unable to touch pad or label we pay
attention to where and how things were
produced visa ninety percent of our
clothing is produced here in Germany and
ten percent in Poland caught Wilson
baleen on templates and what's very
important to us one is that under no
circumstances do we work with leather or
fur we have a 0 / 0 the new policy nada
zero fire policy holidays international
style has struck a chord the media
response in Germany is resounding but
Kirsten Gifford owner of the PR agency
silk relations represents many German
designers and knows that positive
reviews can be deceptive virtue designer
how my cake I it's not much of a problem
for German designers to get into the
media at least not if they have a good
press agent but being able to buy
something from the same German designers
is a different story the retail sector
is very reluctant to take the risk of
putting new talent on the market this is
something of the eight hundred or so
fashion designers in Berlin no more than
a dozen are established on the market
many end up leaving Germany the Berlin
label Oakland has been based in London
since 2014 and it already has access to
buyers there
so far cola de himself has only reached
German customers through his online shop
difficulty in Germany is on two levels
it's on the retail level but it's also
on the consumer level and until both of
these customers decide that they are
actually interested in something other
than no locked Winston there is no hope
we keep forcing our people out and it
really makes me angry it really makes me
angry we have real talent here but they
have no audience at the show in berlin
the three hundred or so invited guests
take their seats while backstage the
models and fitters make last-second
preparations even if it's anything but
routine for Bobby Cola day he seems
quite relaxed the prices for his
creations range from 250 to fifteen
hundred euros and he's got a clear idea
of his typical client this is Alfie and
father animal would definitely be a very
forthright woman a very curious woman
open-minded athletic quick lively
energetic brash just downright cool Emma
Bobby call a day has been nominated for
the Woolmark fashion award after the
winner is announced on monday holiday
could find his light shining more
brightly than ever
you